take a look at big mike was given a
couple extra days rest after his last
start little forearm tightness but no
limitations on him according to manager
rockabaldelli so
be interesting to see how he attacks
this yankee lineup
and le mayhew lines that in the air to
right field that ball is going to be off
the top of the wall
la mayhew hustling at a second and he is
in there with a leadoff double and just
his second extra base hit since may 7.
dribbled in front of the plate
and jeffers has time to make the flip
and the inning
so pineda gives up an opening double to
the mayhew but strands him at second
base a scoreless top of the first and
jordan montgomery going to be the 12th
start of the year and you see that 3-1
record 15 walks against 59 strikeouts in
the seven home runs does it throw across
his body see where he lands straight
ahead
swinging in a miss down goes garlic and
montgomery
records the strikeout josh donaldson
steps to the plate now
he has become a
person of interest in the yankee
universe thanks to his comments about
garrett cole saying the other day
is it a coincidence that gary cole's
spin rate numbers went down yesterday
after four minor leaguers got suspended
for 10 games
that's a fair ball and dropped to third
by hershela and donaldson will reach
trying to make a backhanded play down
the line donaldson will reach with what
i believe will be an infield hit
and that's loop to right field a base
hit donaldson around second he'll go to
third
and sono flaring one just barely out of
the outfield grass but he'll take it
brings up jeffers who's been swinging
the bat very well since he's been
held back up
down the line
bear down the
line donaldson scoring ceno being waved
around a great at back for ryan jeffers
and the twins take a two-nothing lead
well looked like he got that curveball
that he threw him the first pitch that
he didn't have as good a swing on this
time able to foul off some tough pitches
keep the at-bat alive take a look at it
here this curveball actually would end
up below the zone but
just enough to keep that ball fair
has a first spit strike in the first
five yankee hitters the old want to
swing a fly ball to right towards the
corner garlic back drifting on the track
reaches out and makes a great catch on
the warning track down the right field
line
full extension stayed on his feet the
entire time tremendous effort by garlic
one out what a play
outstanding route danny looking back at
the replay it was diagonal from the
get-go it wasn't parallel with the track
had a great route and a phenomenal catch
bucks and began a rehab assignment
tonight
swinging a piece there goes the helmet
that happens often
with hasta dea sort of part of the
the lore of
pasta deal who lose the hat will you
lose the helmet play all over the
diamond
pokes that into right judges there one
down he's talked about having a little
bit of a chip on his shoulder as a 28th
round pick trying to climb to the big
leagues the two two
montgomery gets a call off the inside
corner strike three
and
garlic is down looking
duhar bats right-handed in left field
tonight oh what a catch ostadil at third
a blistering line drive and a great
catch by the turtle oh he was ready to
go right here this is incredible
the reaction time
this ball jumped off the bat right here
but 109 miles an hour
almost looked like a soccer goalie on a
free kicker things just seem to happen
around him when he plays
whether it's entertaining pop-ups where
he takes his hat off or
whatever it is came inside stole
retired nine men in a row
got a little help from his friend at
third base
high fastball got him
and pineda strikes out judge out number
one on the fourth yeah and he's throwing
enough strikes to get a chase on a pitch
out of the zone the hitters are up there
anticipating that ball being around the
plate somewhere and just perfectly
located
line to simmons who lays down to make
the catch
and pineda survives the two-out threat
starting to turn
we'll make you up with judge on deck
le mayhew has doubled tonight
and struck out looking le mayhew rips
that to left field to base hit
and duar is going to be held up at third
as the throw went up the line and the
yankees have the bases loaded with one
out
judge up bases loaded one out yankees
trailing two nothing their biggest
threat of the night by far right here
another 3-2 ball four outstanding plate
appearance from judge
that will score the yankees first run of
the game
it's 2-1
and the bases remain loaded
baldelli coming out glad we're gonna
have to battle back here the one-two in
the dirt block by jeffers here comes
gardner he will score and this game is
tied at two
routine to simmons
and alkalo all things considered did a
nice job came in with the bases loaded
only one man scored we're tied at two
swing and a miss
garlic
is down
for the third time tonight via strikeout
he went around
polanco retired on strikes
montgomery has sat down seven straight
we go to the sixth it's a 2-2 game the
yankees are set up here in the sixth
gardner lifts that in the air to left
field we'll see if sanchez goes he is
coming here's the throw cut off
and sanchez scores and the yankees
take a 3-2 lead and should that throw
have been cut off that reaction tells
you all need all you need to know
the o2
he got him
jeffers went around
two away here in the sixth so the
right-handed hitter ref snider coming up
and that's gonna do it for jordan
montgomery oh he's gonna stay out there
well that's a classic case of jordan
montgomery talking his way back into it
the emotion he showed on the mound
changed that man's mind
a blast to left center field
and gone off the top of the wall
lonnick will score ref snyder to second
with an rbi double
and ref snyder crumpled at second base
as it turned out rob ref schneider did
get a big hit against the yankees but
had to come out of the ball game after
his game tying double and so now here is
le mayhew second and third one out
le mayhew grounds that one right to
second here comes wade he is safe
the throw gets away and the yankees take
a 4-3 lead
judge
serves that to the right side polanco to
second front on to first not in time and
duarte scores
and the yankees extend their lead to 5-3
the first guy to go through the air
force academy and make it to the major
leagues a lot of good swings tonight
from gary sanchez
sanchez
hits that in the air to left and deep
that ball is gone and the yankees
finally deliver the big blow
it's a 7-3 bombers lead
picking ball and he gets his first big
league strikeout
jeffers throws the ball towards the
twins dugout here's ann duharr
and duhar absolutely smashes that
second deck laser
it's eight three yankees
double play grounder
and the throw way up the line by wade
and into the twins dugout and coming in
will be learning
rolled slowly to third or shella across
the diamond and that will do it
the yankees win it 8-4